The OC wanted to do a bold biopsy for gene reference. Are we still a no doing this biopsy?
My grandfather died from the same would also would you let me know when you have looked at the
OC summary of anything else before I move forward? I did look at the office visit summary and I didn't
see anything else that we didn't discuss so that's why I didn't call you back. As far as the
bold biopsy I don't I'm still at odds of why they would want that unless there is you know if
I would just that's what I would just ask why do you need that for gene reference? Is that going
to change the way the chemo that you use if I'm going to do chemo? Is that going to change what
is that going to change? That's that's the question I would just honestly ask. Well though we just
if it's if you if you can't get a straight answer no we just need it in your file well then you
don't need it in my file so but if it's no that's if it's this then we're going to do this
drug if it's this then we're going to do this drug well then okay now we gave an answer
and maybe we'll do that when we get to the point of deciding that we're going to do that next step
remember that was step number three right so it's if they gave me a good answer or why and not
well this is just what we do you know that's not a good answer so if they gave me a good answer that
you're going to you're going to stick an needle in me you're going to put me under surgery
just so you can complete your file or isn't going to help with the decision making process
and how would it help with the decision making process what would you do different what would you
find what are you looking for that's the questions I would ask and then I feel comfortable making the
decision moving forward and by all means we would discuss that.